am Tag 4 sendet Nova dem Team ein Code
yellow was bedeutet das seven vs white
für Sie genau hier endet in dieser Folge
behandeln wir die Abholung aus Sicht des
Teams und gehen darauf ein wie der
Alltag im Basiscamp aussieht wenn euch
das wie ein bisschen gefällt und ihr uns
unterstützen wollt dann vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren um die weitere
Folge nicht zu verpassen viel Spaß
das heutige Video wird euch präsentiert
von Igal ist ein Cashback Anbieter bei
dem über 1800 Online Shops gelistet sind
und so bei fast jedem eurer online
einkaufen sparen können dazu gehören
about you Media Markt Booking.com falls
ihr so wie wir eine Reise zu buchen habt
und natürlich noch eine Menge weitere
Shops und das ganze funktioniert so wenn
ihr mit ihr gerade in einem
Partnerschaft etwas kauft erhält die
gerade eine Provision die bis zu 90% an
euch weitergegeben wird ihr also Geld
zurück bekommt und genau dadurch Geld
spart das Beste das ganze ist kostenlos
kein Vertrag keine Abonnement und keine
versteckten Kosten es ist und bleibt
kostenlos neben der App für iOS und
Android gibt es eine Browser Extension
die euch sofort anzeigt wenn ihr in dem
Partner Shop unterwegs seid also Geld
sparen könnt über den ersten Link und
wirklich nur über den ersten Link
erhaltet ihr explosiv 10 € stark
Guthaben anstatt den 5 € diesmal
normalerweise gibt checkt das also aus
fangt an zu sparen bei den Käufen die
ihr eh im Internet tätigen würdet ich
bedanke mich vielmals und euch viel Spaß
mit dem Video
alles gut alles gut Cooldown alles ist
gut hi ich bin Nova ich bin streamerin
und Youtuberin und ich gehe an die ganze
Sache erbfechtig aber auch sehr
motiviert dran und ich werde versuchen
die meisten Kokosnüsse aufzumachen wenn
es mir gelingt und hoffe auf jeden Fall
dass ich länger als Dave und länger als
zwei Tage durchhalten werde
richtig geile spot
was mache ich hier
oh Gott oh Gott ist aber geil ey ich
habe Bock ich bin stolz ich hoffe ich
darf bis dahin ja ich fange jetzt schon
an durch zu drehen
irgendwie bin ich so richtig so fertig
einfach
[Musik]
diesen Knopf einfach zu drücken warum
ist es so anstrengend also warum ist es
so schwierig für dich gerade geil
[Musik]
ich habe das von mir gar nicht gekannt
das ist so verzweifelt war also ich habe
so
geschrien auch wichtig und so gemeint
ich war so panisch einfach
das war wirklich der Grund wo ich dann
auch gesagt habe so ich kann nicht mehr
ich muss jetzt hier abbrechen
also
von Nova bekommen werden jetzt als
nächstes die Koordinaten sichern und
mitnehmen zusammen unter medizinische
Equipment auf das Boot aufmachen und
nach oben fahren um Nova aus dem
Dschungel zu holen parallel werden wir
probieren über das Satelliten Telefon
noch Kontakt mit ihr auch zu nehmen um
zu schauen was eigentlich los ist mental
kannst du nicht mehr okay wir sind so
ungefähr in 20 Minuten halbe Stunde da
musste dir keine Sorgen machen okay
alles klar bis gleich aber was genau ist
eigentlich auf Seiten des Teams seit der
Aussetzung passiert
damit Notfälle aber auch vernünftig
entgegengenommen werden konnten war die
Notfallzentrale im Camp 24/7 besetzt
ausgestattet mit Computer für GPS
Überwachung Satellitentelefon um Anrufe
entgegennehmen zu können und Sirene um
alle Teammitglieder schnell und einfach
wecken bzw in die Zentrale holen zu
können waren immer zwei Teammitglieder
der Aufgabe zugeteilt die zentrale zu
überwachen in den verschiedenen
Schichten musste man also immer bereit
sein den mehrfach während den Tagen
geprobten und optimierten Notfallplan
einleiten zu können in der Base zu
bleiben und genauestens zu wissen was zu
tun ist damit das Team im Notfall
jederzeit erreichbar ist mussten mehrere
Wege der Kontaktaufnahme errichtet
werden im Gegensatz zu Schweden gibt es
auf Sanität nämlich keinen
Mobilfunkempfang im technikkoffer den
jeder Teilnehmer mitbekommen hat
befinden sich neben dem Kamera Equipment
ein SOS Gerät und ein Satellitentelefon
das SOS Gerät muss zu jeder Zeit am
Körper des Teilnehmers in direkter Griff
Nähe getragen werden um im absoluten
Notfall immer einen Gott red senden zu
können auch wenn man sich nicht im
eigenen Lager befindet außerdem wird
über dieses Gerät zweimal täglich der
Code green und wie in novascal bei
Abholung ein cordello gesendet der Code
Green ist der einzige Indikator fürs
Wohlergehen der Teilnehmer und bei
Ausbleiben eines Signals würde sofort
Alarm geschlagen werden über das Gerät
kann außerdem mittels GPS der Standort
des Teilnehmers ermittelt werden was
stündlich vom Team im Basecamp getan
wird so kann man nicht nur sehen ob der
Teilnehmer sich noch bewegt und somit
offensichtlich noch alles gut ist
sondern die Rettungskräfte Wissen im
Ernstfall auch genau wo sie für eine
Bergung hin müssen im häufig sehr
dichten Dschungel ist das unheimlich
wichtig um entscheidende minuten zu
sparen vor der Aussetzung wurde wie bei
allen anderen Prozessen die Handhabe mit
dem Gerät natürlich genauso erklärt wir
gehen im Grunde alle Geräte jeder
Teilnehmer einmal durch und drücken
diesen SOS Knopf
und das testen wir jetzt einmal
was wir sehen sollten ist idealerweise
bekommen wir eine Nachricht auf unser
Gerät dass wir in der Zentrale halten
plus eine Push-Benachrichtigung über
einen Telegramm bot den wir extra
installiert haben weil wir keinen
Empfang auf der Insel haben und auf
dieser Karte sollten ebenfalls
Nachrichten Einkommen und damit wir alle
Geräte testen machen wir das jetzt hier
mit jedem Gerät und zwar gleichzeitig
das bedeutet dieses SOS wird jetzt
gleich dann hier auf dieser Karte
erscheinen oder nicht exakt mit dem GPS
Koordinaten genau die Koordinaten werden
auch mitgesendet allerdings tracken wir
auch die genaue Position der Teilnehmer
einmal pro Stunde das heißt wir wissen
ja wo wir es ausgesetzt haben dort
werden wir dann auch wiederfinden wir
sehen auf den Geräten überall es gibt
einen SOS Sendevorgang jetzt heißt es
abzuladen das geht natürlich nicht so
schnell zu Hause wie eine
whatsapp-nachricht zu versenden das in
der Regel bei unserem letzten Test hat
es drei Minuten gedauert eine Nachricht
abzuschicken und zwei Minuten die zu
empfangen so was wir jetzt sehen ist
hier das Wichtigste auf unserer Karte
die Teilnehmer haben Notfälle ausgelöst
Protokoll Sehens hier das
Satellitentelefon das wäre immer am Mann
tragen hat ebenfalls die Nachrichten
bekommen in Form einer SMS wir hören uns
jetzt gehen um die ganzen
sos-nachrichten rein und am wichtigsten
unser telegram bot funktioniert das ist
mit Abstand das wo wir am schnellsten
drauf reagieren können weil wir einfach
Push Benachrichtigungen bekommen und
natürlich hier maximal viele Leute
benachrichtigt werden
das internationale rettungscenter
hat quasi bestätigt dass die Notfall
jetzt gerade bekommen hat hier ist es
nur ein SOS Test den wir jetzt wieder
abbrechen werden und der praktische
Service hier mit der SOS-Taste ist dass
man mit einer international tätigen
Einsatzzentrale verbunden wird die
weltweit Herkunft und Rettungseinsätze
koordiniert allerdings ist das hier
nicht so nötig weil wir selber
professionelles Team vor Ort haben mit
Helikopter und medical team also am Ende
des Tages wurden die SOS Knöpfe
umprogrammiert so dass der Notruf an uns
geht anstatt an die das globale
Rettungssystem sondern kann man das
sagen ganz genau Zeit war jetzt 7
Minuten das waren 7 Minuten allerdings
hat es auch nur so lange lange gedauert
weil wir die Geräte vorhin erst
überdacht gelagert hatten wo der Empfang
nicht so groß war hier mit sich auf den
freien Himmel ging es deutlich schneller
das heißt wir hoffen bei den Teilnehmern
dass sie den SOS-Knopf drücken wenn sie
ja freie sich zum Himmel haben bzw am
Strand sind dann geht's deutlich
schneller was ist im Dschungel wenn
jetzt wirklich dichtes Wetterdach ist
geht das überhaupt durch oder dauert
einfach länger funktionieren die Geräte
extremst eingeschränkt wir haben bei
anderen Expeditionen auch hier in Panama
die Erfahrung gemacht dass so ein Signal
durch das Blätter Dach des Dschungels
auch mal für drei Tage komplett
blockiert sein kann
Realität was wird dann machen werden
[Musik]
lassen wir es einmal für den Test aber
dann weiß auch jeder die auf der Insel
dass ein Notfall ausgelöst wurde und ja
die Rettungskräfte machen sich auf den
Weg über das zweite Gerät zu
Kommunikation das Satellitentelefon kann
der Teilnehmer direkten Kontakt zu Basis
aufnehmen gerade bei Verletzungen oder
allgemeinen Situationen die Erklärung
benötigen ist das unheimlich wichtig
natürlich wurde die Patrouille welche
mir im letzten Video erklärt und gezeigt
haben auch weiter durchgezogen im zwei
bzw drei Schichtsystem haben sich immer
jeweils einen Bootsfahrer und ein
Teammitglied gegenseitig abgelöst und
die Insel vom Norden aus bewacht um
fremde Boote fernzuhalten außerdem wurde
der eben angesprochene Notfallplan mit
verschiedenen Szenarien und Uhrzeiten
jeden Tag neu gebrot und wirklich auf
alles vorbereitet zu sein im
reibungslosen Ablauf nicht unbedingt
zuträglich war beispielsweise eine
fiebrige Erkrankung unseres Notarztes
des Islam worauf wir natürlich
vorbereitet waren was die Situation aber
nicht einfacher machen Mama
aber auch gute medizinische Neuigkeiten
wie das Verhalten von Johannes Wunder
hat mir zu verzeichnen inklusive
anschließen grüner Fadenentfernung nicht
mehr
das Militär mit dem wir mittlerweile
eine ziemlich gute connection aufgebaut
hatten kam vorbei um sich in der
Hacienda ein Sandwich für ihre
Mittagspause abzuholen und meinst du die
kommen um uns zu helfen oder um uns eine
Ansage zu machen ich hoffe das Paddy die
irgendwie angerufen hat und die jetzt
irgendwie für uns hier so ein bisschen
kontrollieren können mit und auf unsere
Basecamp hat das Unwetter mit dem die
Teilnehmer an Tag 3 zu kämpfen hatten
keinen halten
das Thema überhaupt kein Problem damit
wir genießen das anders sieht's
vermutlich bei den Teilnehmern aus viel
Spaß Jungs und Mädels
also auch abseits des ganzen Spaßes ist
uns aufgefallen dass das Wetter eine
gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit mit sich bringt
der Strom ist gerade in unserem
kompletten Camp ausgefallen dadurch auch
das Internet und dadurch haben wir nicht
volle Einsicht in unserer gps-netzwerk
wo wir den Standort in der Teilnehmer
die draußen sind abrufen können das
gerade etwas problematisch und wir
müssen schnellstmöglich eine Lösung
dafür finden
[Musik]
Tag 3 wo die Kandidaten ausgesetzt
werden bisher hatten die ziemlich Glück
mit dem Wetter aber jetzt bricht es
gerade aus allen Wolken ich hoffe die
Shelter die die Kandidaten gebaut haben
halten das jetzt aus wir haben natürlich
eine erhöhte Gefahren
wird jetzt richtig heftig
Teilnehmer ausgesetzt der erste Tag
vergeht Code Greens der zweite Tag
vergeht nur Code Greens Tag 3 nur Kurt
Greens und wir dachten schon [ __ ] wir
haben es zu leicht gemacht die werden es
alle schaffen die werden sich das schön
irgendwie unter dem Palmen Vergnügen so
das ist nicht hart genug gewesen wir
werden ja nur den Vergleich zum letzten
Jahr wo zu dem Zeitpunkt schon drei
Leute raus waren so und zu dem Zeitpunkt
noch alle drin was natürlich cool ist
für die Teilnehmer aber unter Umständen
schwierig für die Serie um die Spannung
irgendwie aufrecht zu halten weil wenn
du nicht diese Gefahr ist dass Leute
ausscheiden können dann ist es halt eher
so ein Urlaub ne und dann kam Tag 4 das
war der Tag an dem wir unseren ersten
Code yellow erhalten haben
das Gute an der Situation war Nova hat
sich gemeldet wir hatten eine Verbindung
auch über Satellitentelefon der Arzt ist
rangegangen wir wussten es ist kein
medizinischer Notfall das heißt wir
hatten nicht den ultimativen Stress aber
es war natürlich auch für uns ein Test
wie schnell wir am Ende Verbot
zumindestens bei einem Teilnehmer sein
können wir sind hier unten mit der
Hacienda das heißt das Boot wird hier
diese Küste entlangfahren und das Gute
ist dass wir nur den den Spot von Fritz
und vom Auto passieren werden das heißt
die anderen Teilnehmer werden davon aus
mitbekommen das Team hier vor Ort hat
performt alles lief hier am Schnürchen
ein Team ist losgezogen zu dem
geburtstagskapitän hat die wach gemacht
hat gesagt wir müssen los
ja die wussten was zu tun war
[Musik]
willkommen in der Zivilisation
wo du komplett alleine bist
und du hast ja keine Entertainment gar
nicht so wenn ich mich dahin setzen komm
schon Autor banks oder sowas Netflix
weißt du so aber das
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was machst du jetzt nach dem Essen
dann in eine frische Unterhose frische
Unterwäsche frische Klamotten
und dann 18 April
[Musik]